So plus like crickets are telling you this and so
they're a very reliable source.
Okay.
So you see the star is star recurs as a Motif in Pinocchio.
And one of the more interesting elements of it here is that when Jupiter wants
to transform his puppet Marionette,
whose being played by forces that operate behind the scenes,
which is really good definition of the persona from a union perspective,
right?
And also something indicative of something like an ideological or conceptual
possession.
Japan know who's a good guy,
he's positive father figure re lifts his,
even though he's a patriarchal figure,
right?
And a very competent one.
He's still even lifts his eyes up to something that transcends his motive,
be positive as it is and wishes that his creation would undertake the kind of
transformation that would make it autonomous and fully functional as a moral
agent.
No strings.
Right.
So that's very interesting.
I think soldier Pittson said the salvation of mankind lies only in making
everything that concern of all.
That's a pretty decent star light goal,
I would say.
And so what happens in the Pinocchio story is that because,
and I think this is a symbolic representative of what I just described to you,
that happens at a genetic level if you put yourself in new situations.
So Jupiter is roughly culture in the Pinocchio Story,
right?
He's,
he's a craftsman.
he's uh,
and he makes Pinocchio.
So He's,
he's who's his son,
he's the socializing agent and
he aims for something above mere socialization,
which is I think part of the mysterious element of human beings.
You know,
in our scientific models we'd basically have socialization and biology,
but there's always a third element,
mythological stories,
which is whatever you might construe as the spontaneous action of consciousness
that's associated with free will.
And you know,
that's just basically being conceptualized in religious terms.
There's something akin to the soul.
Now,
we don't have a category for that scientifically because what we try to do
scientifically is to reduce everything either to socialization or to biology.
But it isn't clear to me that that's,
it's perfectly reasonable from the perspective of practicality at a scientific
level.
You don't want to multiply explanatory principles beyond necessity.
But there's many things that that doesn't come to terms with,
such as the fact that we all treat each other as autonomous beings with free
will and that that seems to work.
And that if we stopped doing that,
then things go to hell very,
very rapidly.
So,
and the mere fact that we have been able to conceptualize what that conscious
freewill might be,
metaphysically or physically,
it doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
It just means that we don't understand it.
I mean what,
it was only in the last 15 years that we discovered that 95% of the universe was
made out of some kind of matter that we can't even,
whose properties we can't even imagine except that it seems to have mass.
So anyways,
what happens is when Japan will reach,
lifts his eyes up to the star.
So it's society aligning itself with the proper goal with regards to individual
development,
right?
So,
so there instead of society being at odds with the individual,
they line up and then what happens is nature comes on board.
And that's the Blue Fairy and Pinocchio Story.
And that's seems to me to be a symbolic representation of what happens
biologically when,
when you set the goal properly,
get your culture behind you and move into the world,
is that there's a biological transformation that occurs as a consequence of
that,
which means that a bunch of you that hasn't been turned on turns on.
And I guess one question would be is what would you be like if you turned on
everything inside of you that could be turned on?
Well,
that's a good goal.
That's a good thing to find out.
So.